d'oublier la caméra ça tourne et voilà
donc s'il y peint bas vous imagine que
ce que ce 27 septembre chaque année
c'est quand même quelque chose de deux
forts et 2 et de douloureux parce que
vous vous vous étiez là ce fameux 25
virages j'étais présent mais j'ai vu
tout là tous les ans de partir à la
mairie après avoir eu le coup de
tambours traditionnels
oui je vois encore tous ces hommes
partis est la muse est parce qu il soit
disant qu'il va aller travailler faire
les transférer courroux des travaux pour
les allemands
quand vous voyez ça vous comprenez pas
en plus vous êtes un petit garçon vous
avez dix ans de 6 en six ans
est ce que vous venez de ce qui s'est
passé dans votre tête quand vous les
avez vus partir ben thaber eux j'ai vu
ma maman pète est triste c'est déjà
d'une part un patient une femme ça que
son mari pas comme ça travailler pour
les allemands c'est parce que ça peut
donner donc je sais papa il a fait à peu
près 20 mètres qui s'est retourné il m'a
dit philippe soit sage avec la moment
voilà son dernier mot qui m'a dit c'est
venu après la tournée le dos ou les
parties avec les autres camarades puis
après je n'ai plus jamais revu combien
de temps il s'est passé avant que vous
sachiez bas de deux mois
voilà presque oui alors c'est ils ont
été jugés le 27 septembre 44 donc trois
semaines après le prêt dans l' angoisse
terrible alors c'est une dame qui avait
des cousins est au bon qu'a pu passer
quand même
à travers bois où j'ai pas trop où est
la forme et alors là c'est et le le cri
de détresse de tours village c'était
l'affolement mon mari mon fils alors
trois fils dans la même maison des
contes presque les âges ce sujet alors
des maris des pères y en a et les quatre
enfants y laissèrent quatre enfants et
comment on a fait après dans le village
parce qu'ils étaient décimées village
natal heroes la dalle et tout le monde
s'est entraidé les les
courageusement ont remplacé les hommes
avec la faux avec la fourche à fumier
avec tout ça a repris le dessus petit à
petit il ya aussi beaucoup d de la part
du pasteur de l'époque tout seul parce
heureux non de l'époque a été déporté
donc le palace le pasteur carvena même
suivi les dégâts que je souligne bien
delà du locle est venu remplacer le
pasteur donc à il a contacté son village
pour apporter du matériel détracteurs de
déshabille pour les habitants des taudis
donc il est décédé maintenant mais c'est
un homme bon qui je n'oublie pas été
facile on a vous en parlait encore entre
vous de cette histoire là on a tellement
si on en parle cette c'est plus en
tant qu'une révolte
disons entre votre copain ou un très
vieil habitant qui restent ici
il n'aurait pas fallu faire comme ça
n'aurait pas fallu une maquis il aurait
fallu les avoir autrement entre mon nom
mais la cérémonie nous rappelle à
l'ordre
elle est importante oui oui et je
voudrais bien même de tout coeur que
notre président machores j'ai vu parce
que je l'aï vu aller à oradour-sur-glane
voudrait bien qu'une fois ils sont
informés qu'ils sachent que tout bon a
eu la croix de guerre et la légion
d'honneur et qui viennent nous en aurait
une fois
pourquoi pas sa présence et puis
compatir un petit peu de ce qu'on a
souffert
enfin nous on a souffert d autres ont
souffert elle encore qui souffrent je
répéterai vite et sur dix ans c'est tout
c'était ce massacre
parce que mon village stratégique avec
des chemins qui y vont un peu partout
ben les réfractaires qui voulait pas
aller travailler en allemagne
qu'est ce qu'ils aiment ils ne seraient
plus jette au bon y retirer les fuji
qu'avait émis depuis l'alarmé de 40
un peu partout pour mettre dehors
l'ennemi voyez des fusils qu'on retire
depuis 40 à 44 il était pas mal rouillé
donc dans la forge et paternel le grand
père me disait des fois d'avoir joué aux
bills je voulais qu'ils réparent et des
fusils et d'eau alors que c'était bien
est-ce que c'était bien ou pas bien ça
je sais pas le chef du maquis là d'une
fois à certains qui voulaient pas aller
dans le maquis parce que j'étais
anabaptistes donc il voulait parler de
leur prochain un peu normal il a dit
après la guerre il y aura des
représailles
bon alors là sur les deux frères y en a
qui étaient au mathis n'y a pas été tout
le temps parce que là ils avaient des
bêtes aussi est le chef du maquis
s'effectuer le premier le 9 septembre 44
alors alors après ça fait ça fait
beaucoup jaser ça fait je me rappelle
que ma maman il y avait une fois vous
savez c'est pas bien ce que vous faites
pas ce que ça va mal se terminer samedi
allemands vont vont pas laisser passer
ça comme ça
mêlez vous de vos cuisines je me
rappelle qu'à 10 à 27 septembre 44
quand ils sont arrivés personnes
la soupçonner ce qui allait se passer
maintenant non parce que le village
était cerné peut-être je peux vous le
dire mais discrètement discrètement mais
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'ils avaient
déjà fait des prisonniers et à la mairie
ya de ces gars là qui sont évadés du
comme prisonnier qu'ont reconnu dgac a
mené la soupe à six pales encore fournir
la nourriture pour les allemands qui des
deux camps dans la forêt du ferry mont
donc oui alors après il ya le nul est à
manu de la gestapo de belfort quand ils
ont descendu en janvier pour se réfugier
dans une usine il ya encore des
allemands du camp de prisonniers qui
sont ni arrivée là bas
et puis l'officier allemand je sais pas
quel grade il avait il a dit vous avez
mal mené aux hommes qui ce qui était
faux vous ce réfugié donc à fallait 40
alors rien et que 39 parce que l'autre
c'est un alsacien est ce qu il a pu
corriger ce qu'il a pu dialoguer avec
cette officiellement ni qu'il a je sais
pas donc un oeil 39 et ceux qui sont
partis ben c'est à dire moi j'ai lu donc
le pape a fusillé ça faisait huit de ma
famille donc mon cousin
charles le père est il était fusillé que
mon papa et puis son frère fernand
perrais 18 ans il est mort à illkirch
île riche en allemagne de misère donc ce
n'est pas l'onu il y en a qui ont été
fusillés à bonvillars et aux bons aussi
et le pasteur est revenue parce que
pierre marie est revenue avec ses
ouailles aujourd'hui les enfants s qui
viennent vous posez des questions
annoncé le 27 septembre
non non non et au bon tout le monde
travaille presque laissé jour là et on
voit pas beaucoup de personnes des taux
bon mais ça moi et mon fils là n'est pas
là pour le monde ma fille travaille les
serres dans un lycée donc elle aurait pu
prendre un jour mon temps de jeu d'ea
lusine je les trouvais mon chez lui
disait je vais bien journée de 7 à
problèmes tu auras toujours vous
regrettez vous la vie et aillent tous
bon on parle du ce2 de cette douloureuse
histoire que le 27
elle près puis on ans raconte un peu
comme ça mais soyez ça beaucoup changer
tu sais année donc il ya beaucoup de
maisons neuves qui sont qui sont à
nouveau habité par des personnes qui
n'ont pas été touchés du tout donc ça
les intéresse pas peur de le dire mais
la nappe titre qui viendront dans mais
il connaît pas tout le monde a été donc
celui qui viennent à d'habiter et puis
qui veut venir à la cérémonie et c'est
important
ah oui il faut qu'elle est toujours
mieux pour maintenir le souvenir mal ce
niveau là puisque dans ce monde disent
pas et on a des gens qui meurent encore
peut-être sujet ou expliquer ou ce qu'on
veut dans un des massacres comme ça
il faut plus qu'un nez on est ami avec
les allemands parce que pendant la
guerre nous quelle le pape a été fusillé
il ya des allemands qui sont venus
remplacer les hommes dans les fermes
alone on a eu un officier allemand
il s'appelait france libertés ils
étaient deux kayser le terme c'est dans
le palatinat
alors il est venu avec plusieurs qui
sont plutôt bons donc nous on a récupéré
france et y logeaient dans la ferme de
mes grands parents en saas il à rester
touchant temps là bas et après grâce à
la croix rouge il a pu correspondre avec
son fils et sa femme en allemagne donc
après la guerre ils sont venus nous à
mes grands-parents et ya huit jours
son fils avec son fils est venu me dire
bonjour et il a voulu que je le mène au
cimetière pour voir la tombe de mon papa
alors que s'ils n'aimaient pas il n'a
pas de bonnes relations avec eux ce qui
s'est passé avec les allemands dont 44
non plus ni ni ni d'hitler n'y aurait
plus entendre parler de ça il m'a dit
philippe ne parle pas de ça pour mon ami
oui mais il était qu'il était
reconnaissant gendre à ses taux et son
papa a beaucoup aidés comme s'ils
travaillaient pour lui et pourtant c'est
un seul weibel et un adjudant chef est
très correct
le grand père y a des cheveux pas de
loger dans ma ferme et là tu couches
travers la vieille grand mère où je
couche maintenant d'aller dans la maison
qui a là il ya dit si tu t'es valdes
tu es libre je suis pas responsable de
toi mais je voudrais mieux pas il ya des
deux super et je vous donne ma parole
d'anciens officiers que je ferai mon
temps ici et il n'est jamais parti
bk encore y avait des bombes des bons
allemands si c'est comme tous il ya du
bon partout c'est le seul idéalisé des
légendes et fois mal ou si j'étais
soldat n'aurait pas dû aller d'ailleurs
à ce que j'étais pupille de la nation ne
les fait 29 mois et demi j'ai fait lure
après j'étais en tunisie n'aurait pas dû
aller non plus bas si j'y suis allé j'ai
laissé mes grands-parents se débrouiller
et la ferme c'est la présence regroupées
trois périodes
je suis là j'ai quand même la retraite
du combattant mais j'ai un petit peu
quand même quelque chose
merci beaucoup voyagé voilà je vous dis
ça sans rancune maintenant de rien
compris peut pas avoir de rancune
non ça a quand même vous versez votre
site
ah ben c'est 27 septembre et la
bouleverser votre compte mais aussi mais
bon j'ai la foi que je suis je suis
content de vivre quand même et puis de
l'une des petites filles j'ai mon fils
que j'ai beaucoup d'amis d'amis puis des
chèvres avec des animaux puis
détracteurs qu'ils sont vieux comme moi
combien est-ce que la presse 88 81 ça
marche quand même